the first in the deadly coronavirus
outbreak the US Embassy in Beijing
confirmed overnight that the first
American has died from the virus at the
epicenter in the Chinese city of Wuhan
the outbreak is responsible for more
than 720 deaths
all but two have occurred in mainland
China more than 34,000 people have been
infected with the virus worldwide
including at least 12 confirmed cases of
the virus right here in the United
States Michael George is here with more
details on the latest death Michael good
morning
well good morning the embassy offered
very few details on the American who
died but we do know they were 60 years
old and that they died on Wednesday in a
hospital in Wuhan the death occurred as
hundreds of American evacuate for their
return to the US roughly 300 American
evacuated military bases around the u.s.
all of them coming from Wuhan China the
epicenter of the corona virus outbreak
certainly it's it's concerning dr. Henry
welcomed the CDC leads the coronavirus
response team at Travis Air Force Base
in California where more than 200
passengers are under quarantine walk
says five of the evacuees displayed
symptoms and were hospitalized fever or
shortness of breath along with any call
for example other flights loaded with
evacuees landed in Omaha Nebraska and
San Antonio Texas where health officials
wearing hazmat suits escorted passengers
off planes to start a 14 day quarantine
I am happy to report that we did not
find any evidence of illness among the
passengers who landed
here today the largest single group of
confirmed infections outside China
exists in Japan on the diamond Princess
cruise ship you can see that this is
tidy house Livie
at least 3400 passengers and crew are
currently on board the ship has been
docked in Yokohama since Wednesday more
than 60 passengers including at least 11
Americans tested positive for the virus
we take our temperature a minimum of
three times a day and in China nearly
sixty million people are still on some
kind of partial or total public
transportation lockdown to try to
contain the virus new research suggests
the Pangolin an endangered mammal whose
scales are highly valued in Chinese
medicine may have passed the virus to
humans and us-based Cruise Lines are
taking their own precautions Royal
Caribbean International and Norwegian
Cruise Lines issued bans for any guests
holding a Chinese Hong Kong or Macau
passport regardless of residency Jeff
all right Michael thank you very much